what is going on there reject nation i always do
this who is what is going on hello what is going
on there reject nation greg here today so we got
a very very big announcement to make we actually
wanted to make this announcement last week last
week john actually caught the vid diesel and then
i thought i was fine but then a few days later
i ended up testing positive so at this moment
still got the vid diesel but i feel good so i told
the team that's right team there's a you'll hear
more on that in just a second i said team we are
making the announcement because i feel good right
now and i want to let the people know so for the
longest time we've been asked if we're ever going
to do this and now since thanks to you the reject
nation we have gotten to a million subscribers we
thought it was about damn time something to really
help celebrate honor being a citizen of the reject
oh my god citizen of the reject nation why have i
never thought about that i've always been saying
subscribe to get accepted to the reject nation
but what about subscribe and become a citizen
of the reject nation i think i finally figured i
think that's the one we got to go in from here on
out anyway citizens of the reject nation i always
said that if we ever did do this that would have
to be something really cool really special really
creative and really collaborative as well and i
know i can resort to making like stupid sarcastic
comments from time to time uh but i just want to
take a moment to say that even though it's just
like at the first day of launch i am already very
proud of everything we have already accomplished
with this i really think that what we have on our
hands here right now is something very special and
at first you might be like is that it but trust me
it's gonna be a little different than when your
average youtuber announces this that's right i'm
comparing myself we're finally gonna have some
goddamn merch there goes greg's hands again we
have officially partnered up with this this super
nerdy store bunch of nerds of a super nerdy store
and we've been approached by people in the past
being like hey you know we must start creating
some apparel beanies whatever we can help you with
that for a variety of reasons we've always said no
never really felt like the right time for some
reason or that we didn't like the feeling of the
clothes we had one for such a brief moment but we
were kind of testing out but we ultimately didn't
like the way the designs were actually going and
we didn't like the clothes so we just got to try
to not let people ever really know about it but
more important than anything else for whoever
really knows me knows that more than what i'm
doing i care more about who i'm working with
so this product launch is not just that of the
real rejects but with a couple of hacks you might
have heard of heavy spoilers and screen crush i
picked up that paul from heavy spoilers and ryan
arie from screen crusher friends of mine don't
embarrass yourself shut the [__] up ryanairy
and then i say best friends but they they don't
ever say it back to me but i know they know
they're just putting up a sarcastic wall the
other day they call me the mclovin of the group
and everyone knows mclovin's the leader all of
us have had ideas and want to create products
and have a shop to represent our brand our brand
they're always still selling software our brand
because we're influencers and we're influencing
you to go to our shop but the main thing that we
end up talking about when it comes to launching a
line like this is just how much of an undertaking
it can be and it truly just excited us at the
thought of us doing it together i know that sounds
a little bit i need to just be sincere so and
one of the ways we've been saying it is we've
partnered up so we can create one place where you
can express your inner nerd and get the kind of
products that help you stand out from the crowd
we joke like we're the avengers coming together
on this you know paul is like iron man and ryan is
like captain america they say i'm like wholesome
but i like to think i'm the thor of the group
now listen i don't think it'd be wise legally
for me to put down some other companies that also
produce nerdy gear but these are better these are
the more if you know you know kind of shirts you
won't get called fake nerd if you rock this [__]
so this place is called zero edition so we've
been working on these for months got way more
coming been going over designs testing them out
everything everything is very high quality they're
things we would actually wear got a whole shipment
coming this week or something wearing them online
actually this jacket that i'm wearing right now uh
was one of the test jackets and there's like the
three others over there with different fabrics and
i said no forget that crap this one this is this
is the fabric the softness this is the jacket
the reject nation's gonna be wearing the shirts
are soft but they'll make you look good you'll
get compliments you'll feel validated they'll
ask where did you get that shirt and you'll tell
them you'll tell them that you favor our shirts
over heavy spoilers and screen crush you know even
though it's not a competition but i'm gonna make
it one they're gonna accentuate the shoulders
arms upper chest gonna be nice to you around
the midsection and as someone who's like always
bloated i tend to be self-conscious about that why
don't i just zip this up right now while we're at
it the designs have been collaborations between us
and a team of designers who have all told me that
they personally elect me more than paul and ryan
but that's not the main point here they're all a
bunch of nerds too like they they're so nerdy way
more nerdy than i could have ever imagined i steal
their lunch box and shove chocolate milk on their
nose river bullies did i don't know but whenever
we pitch designs to them they have that if you
know you know kind of mentality and they always
see the vision fully through like it is so cool
to see things come to life and look better than
how i pencil drew them so yeah they're they're
amazing so we have some great options for you to
rock to show your love for the channel this one
i spend way too much time trying to narrow down
to the one i perfectly like but the other ones
are the ones i'm actually very very very excited
about the regular drops we're going to be doing
the limited the limited run ones a one of a kind
prints is a terminology i heard recently for the
first time i'm like i like that i'm gonna remember
that so when they run out they run out so with us
i was thinking about like with the reject nation
have some of the biggest things we've covered in
the last couple years and sometimes you watch
so many things they just start to mash together
you have an idea where i'm going with this
so our first sick mashup shirt is vecna from
stranger things rocking this is spoilers here by
the spoiler report vecna from netflix's stranger
things rocking the zero zero one jacket from squid
game i know a lot of us when we saw that you can't
trust the number one and then bam was like we love
covering both those shows here so yeah we made
a shirt for you guys there's more designs there
and there's other mashups coming in other designs
but yeah i wanted to that was the one i was
like oh my god i can't wait to wear that once
it's got to be the first one i won this right now
is absolutely the best way to support the channel
and what we do here it took us a long time to find
the right way to proceed confidently this is the
way this is the way so thank you all for being
here but also reject nation it's a democracy we
not only want you to celebrate and identify as a
member of this community but also we value your
input here the reject nation so we'd love to hear
your feedback anything good i'll take credit for
anything bad i'll blame someone else and we'd love
to hear your pitches on more mashup shirt ideas
we're open to suggestions people gotta thank
screen crush and heavy spoilers without them this
would not have been possible sincerely i'm giving
you guys a sincere one we want to thank you the
viewers for supporting us i am beyond thrilled to
show you guys what we have at shopzero edition.com
also if you end up buying something please tweet
your purchases so we can show that we are a worthy
addition to the zero edition and plain and simple
we're just excited to see what the future holds
for for zero edition i want to do a panel one day
of us just talking about this not all the years
of youtubing it's just about zero edition thanks
again and i'll in this sincerely by saying i'm
just honored to be a part of this team um it's
it really is something special you know i just
wanted to make this announcement a little bit fun
but that's kind of like the vibe that we have when
we're all just talking even when we're talking
about things that we should be taking seriously so
it's it's just a really fun place to be a
part of so yeah as much as we have our ideas
you know we also really want to hear what
you guys have to say because a lot of the
inspiration tends to come from what's being
uh generated or being talked about our way
as well thank you guys so much for this
and i'm i'm i really am excited like the
the more than just heavy spoilers and screen crush
like the whole rest of the team are everyone is
just so cool to talk to it's such a blast to
talk with everyone it's so much fun constantly
i wish they would include me
more this tends to be the kind of
stupid vibe that we have going on thank
you again and i'll talk with you all soon